hace algunos vídeos estábamos viendo la
fotosíntesis clásica la fotosíntesis c3
que por cierto se llama c3 porque la
primera vez que fijamos el dióxido de
carbono lo fijamos en una molécula que
tiene una cadena de 3 carbonos ahora
hace algunos vídeos viendo la
fotosíntesis clásica vimos que la enzima
rubisco no sólo permite que reaccione el
dióxido de carbono sino que también
facilita la reacción del oxígeno con la
rigurosa bis fosfato y cuando eso sucede
obtenemos una reacción que no solo es
ineficiente y utiliza un montón de atp y
nh sino que además utiliza rigurosa
bisfosfonatos y no los recupera y
simplemente no nos lleva a ningún lado
así es que cada vez que el oxígeno se
enlaza con la enzima rubisco para
reaccionar con la riva los aviv fosfato
todo se vuelve mucho menos eficiente
ahora lo que vimos en el vídeo pasado es
que hay unas plantas que han logrado
evitar este problema y lo que
qué hacen estas plantas es fijar al
dióxido de carbono en estas células del
mes off y lo que son unas células que si
están en contacto con el aire y lo fijan
en unas cadenas de 4 carbonos llamadas
ok sal acetatos utilizando una enzima
que solo puede fijar al dióxido de
carbono y no al oxígeno y luego
transforman el ocs al acetato en malato
y el malato lo transportan a otras
células que están en un lugar un poco
más profundo en la hoja y ya que está el
mal dato en estas células el mal dato se
descompone en dióxido de carbono y
piruvato y ahora sí en estas células
utilizamos el dióxido de carbono para
hacer el ciclo de calvino original pero
aunque en estas células y tenemos la
enzima rubisco ahora no va a suceder la
foto respiración porque en estas células
únicamente tienen acceso al dióxido de
carbono y no al oxígeno así es que esta
es una forma muy eficiente para producir
azúcares y es por eso que muchas de las
plantas que nosotros consideramos
como buenas productoras de azúcares o de
etanol todas estas plantas en realidad
están haciendo fotosíntesis c4 como el
maíz o la caña de azúcar o el trigo maíz
caña de azúcar trigo estas son plantas
que son súper eficientes a la hora de
producir azúcares porque no se tienen
que preocupar por la foto respiración
ahora también tenemos otras plantas que
realmente no están tan preocupadas por
la eficiencia del ciclo de calvin sino
que están más preocupadas por la pérdida
del vapor de agua y nos podemos imaginar
qué tipo de plantas son esas son plantas
que se encuentran en los desiertos
porque estos es tomás si dejan pasar al
aire pero también dejan salir al vapor
de agua y por supuesto si estoy en una
selva húmeda no me importa pero si me
encuentro en medio del desierto no
quiero perder esta agua por supuesto que
no quiero que el vapor salga por los
estomas en una situación ideal
y me gustaría que los estomas se
cerraran durante el día ok esto es lo
que yo quiero digamos que estamos en el
desierto y si estamos en el desierto
queremos queremos que los estomas se
cierren durante el día si estamos en el
desierto queremos que los estomas se
cierren durante el día y la razón es
porque no quiero que todo el vapor de
agua se escape por mis estomas a lo
largo del día pero el problema es que la
fotosíntesis sucede durante el día y eso
también incluye a las reacciones oscuras
recuerda lo he repetido muchas veces
reacciones oscuras es un muy mal nombre
para ese tipo de reacciones más bien
deberían de llamarse reacciones
independientes de la luz porque también
suceden durante el día ambas reacciones
las independientes de la luz y las
dependientes de la luz sólo suceden
simultáneamente durante el día así es
que la fotosíntesis completa solo sucede
durante el día
y los estomas están cerrados como le
vamos a hacer para obtener dióxido de
carbono porque pues el ciclo de calvin
necesita dióxido de carbono ok
necesitamos dióxido de carbono como
vamos a arreglar este problema
yo quiero cerrar a los estomas durante
el día pero también necesito al dióxido
de carbono durante el día como le
podemos hacer para resolver este
problema
bueno pues las plantas del desierto han
evolucionado para arreglar este problema
y utilizan la fotosíntesis c4 pero en
lugar de fijar el carbono en una célula
exterior y empujarlo a una célula
interior para en ese lugar hacer el
ciclo de calvin en lugar de utilizar
estos dos tipos de células lo que hacen
es utilizar dos tiempos distintos
durante el día y durante la noche así es
que en las plantas camps en las plantas
camps y esta es simplemente la
abreviación de metabolismo ácido de las
crasuláceas porque la primera vez que se
observó este tipo de fotosíntesis
en estas plantas que a su la seas pero
por supuesto a todas las plantas que
hacen este tipo de fotosíntesis los
podemos decir plantas camps y a este
tipo de fotosíntesis se le llama
fotosíntesis camps y ahora estas plantas
podríamos decir que son un subconjunto
de las plantas que realizan fotosíntesis
de cuatro pero en lugar de dividir la
fotosíntesis entre las células
exteriores y las células interiores
dividen a la fotosíntesis entre el día y
la noche aunque éstas son un subconjunto
de las plantas se cuatro subconjunto de
las plantas c4 y lo que hacen es que
durante la noche mantienen sus esto más
abiertos durante la noche mantienen sus
esto más abiertos y logran fijar el
dióxido de carbono ahora todo esto
sucede en las células del mes o phil o
digamos que tenemos una célula del
mesófilo por aquí y durante la noche
cuando no tenemos miedo de perder vapor
de agua los estomas se quedan abiertos
y digamos que por aquí este es una
espuma y está abierto y como es de noche
no tenemos el temor de que se vaya el
vapor del agua y puede entrar por acá el
dióxido de carbono y luego la célula del
mesófilo recibe el dióxido de carbono y
lo fija exactamente de la misma forma
como se fija el dióxido de carbono en la
fotosíntesis c4 así es que tenemos por
aquí el dióxido de carbono tenemos
también a las moléculas p
y todo está siendo facilitado por la
enzima pep carboxilasa que es una enzima
que solo puede reaccionar con el dióxido
de carbono solo facilita que el pp
reaccione con el dióxido de carbono y no
con el oxígeno y luego estos dos juntos
producen malato y eso también lo vimos
por aquí en la fotosíntesis de cuatro
gripe con dióxido de carbono producen
malato que tiene una cadena de 4
carbonos si es que todo esto se utiliza
para producir malato y esta es la clave
del asunto porque aquí los malatos se
almacenan en otros órganos de las
células llamados vacuolas los cuales son
como unos contenedores gigantescos
dentro de la célula y bueno aquí cometió
un grave error porque estoy dibujando
todo esto como si sucediera en la célula
completa cuando en realidad todas estas
reacciones están sucediendo en el
cloroplasto
pero el punto es que el mat latos sale
del cloroplasto y es almacenado en estos
órganos los llamados vacuolas ok el mat
latos se almacena por aquí durante la
noche y al mandato lo podemos ver como
una forma de almacenar dióxido de
carbono durante la noche porque más
adelante durante el día
podemos usar el malato para conseguir
dióxido de carbono y de hecho eso es
justo lo que las plantas camps hacen si
es que durante la noche sucede esto pero
durante el día
esta planta desértica que tal vez
incluso puede ser un cactus pero esta
planta desértica no quiere perder su
vapor de agua por lo que cierra sus esto
más tenemos aquí un estómago pero
durante el día la planta cierra su sexto
más durante el día los estomas están
cerrados y ahorita nos podemos preguntar
oye pero si los estomas están cerrados
como le hace la planta para realizar la
fotosíntesis
bueno pues puede realizar la
fotosíntesis en esa misma célula por
y almacenó todo este mal a todo durante
la noche y ahora el mal dato puede salir
de la vacuola meterse al cloroplasto y
quedarse flotando en el estroma del
cloroplasto y luego el mat latos se
divide en piruvato pero lo que más nos
importa es que también se divide en
dióxido de carbono así es que ahora
tenemos dióxido de carbono y ahora si ya
se puede realizar el ciclo de calvin y
además en un ambiente que únicamente
tiene dióxido de carbono nuestros
estomas están cerrados no está entrando
ningún oxígeno así es que ahora el
dióxido de carbono puede reaccionar con
la rigurosa bis fosfato todo esto por
supuesto catalizado por la enzima
rubisco y sucede todo el ciclo de calvin
y producimos azúcares azúcares así es
que toda esta adaptación es bastante
elegante por acá tenemos estas otras
plantas que se adaptaron para tener una
excelente eficiencia en cuestión de
producir azúcares y estas plantas no
están preocupadas por no
el vapor de agua y lo que hacen es fijar
al carbono en unas células que están
expuestas al aire y después empujan una
versión almacenada del carbono las
células que se encuentran en un nivel
más profundo que no tienen acceso al
aire del exterior y es en estas células
en la profundidad de la hoja donde
realizan el ciclo de calvin y hacen eso
para que no pueda suceder la foto
respiración por otro lado las plantas
del desierto se benefician de este
mecanismo también pero lo hacen de una
forma diferente lo que realmente les
preocupa a las plantas acá es mantener
los estomas cerrados de día para no
perder el vapor de agua así es que lo
que hacen es fijar al carbono durante la
noche pero estamos utilizando el mismo
mecanismo que estamos usando la ctep
carboxilasa y estamos fijando al carbono
durante la noche y almacenándolo para
que durante el día cuando empiezan a
suceder las reacciones dependientes de
la luz
crear atp h pueda salir el mal dato de
la vacuola y de esa forma obtenemos
dióxido de carbono y pueden suceder las
reacciones oscuras
ok las reacciones independientes de la
luz porque repito es el nombre de
reacciones oscuras es un muy mal nombre
porque son reacciones que suceden
durante el día
ok pero aquí ya tenemos dióxido de
carbono y se puede realizar el ciclo de
calvin